[Music]
also very much in love bachelorette
Becca and her fiance Garrett et special
correspondent Christine Johnson spoke to
the happy couple today from New York hey
Christine yes Cameron and I think that
that makes me an honorary member of
bachelor nation I am sure that we will
be seeing Becca and Garrett packing on
the PDA but you know I wanted to know
just how they spent all those months
undercover will you marry me
do you feel as though a weight has been
lifted off your shoulders oh yeah this
the fact that no we don't need to use
code names anymore amazing what kind of
code names did you have
he was Vincent she was Veronica Vincent
and Veronica have you come up with those
yourself yes that Veronica was already
kind of like her alter ego and but the
last name of my phone was bushel peck
and that came from yeah I wrote a little
note like I I love you a bushel and a
peck and so that's how he got that name
the engagement ring is four carats the
next step is a possible move to LA but
what about this pic making its way
around the internet many people think
Beca looks a lot like Garrett's ex-wife
his first marriage was in 2015 and they
split after two months another thing
still haunting Garrett from his past
those Instagram posts where he liked
some controversial memes why did you
like those posts you know I don't know
I'm still sticking with the apology that
I put on Instagram that I just
mindlessly was swiping through on
Instagram and double-tapped and I wasn't
reading into the image I was just taking
the image for what it was so will there
be a TV wedding
Becca and Garrett say not so fast so
we're getting to know each other
yes by the way The Bachelor train keeps
rolling tonight with the premiere of
bachelor in paradise
Cameron Kevin I know you'll be watching
you
[Music]